[музика]
майже 90 років тому собор знищили
більшовики тепер російські
окупанти ракета прилетіла в прави віфтар
святителя Петра він бачите повністю
зруйнований також
частково зруйнований центральний віфтар
23 липня 2023 року російська ракета
влучила в найбільш храм Одеси
спасопреображенський собор я був тут
через 10 хвилин і побачив таку страшну
картину вся площа в
уламках
собор нема ні вікон ні дверей а двері
тут
громадні він
палає дим і Це був великий Шок для мене
і
потрясіння я спробував даже ее взяв
вогнегасник щоби потушити пожежа вона
все сильніше і сильніше була і я кинувся
спасати наші святині загалом тієї ночі
обстріли РФ зруйнували перекриття трьох
поверхів пошкодили внутрішнє оздоблення
та ікони а також повністю знищили
службові приміщення нижньої частини
собору е собор він увібрав собі в собі
всю ц цю вибихову хвилю все в ньому
залишилось
він знов
побудований і побудований по новітнім
технологіям дуже багато бетону І от Це
все він все видержав і все ця вибухова
хвиля залишилась тут та після удару
ракети життя собору не зупинилося поки
верхній храм стоїть понівечений і
обгорілий богослужіння проводять у
[музика]
Нижньому
спасопреображенський собор головний храм
Одеської Єпархії Української
Православної Церкви пов'язаної з
Московським патріархатом тут донедавна
молилися за патріарха Кирила А у 2010
він особисто освячував собор Чому Росія
запустила ракету по храму який
десятиліттями офіційно підпорядковувався
рпц питання На яке тут не мають
відповіді а я б хотів щоб ви його задали
тій стороні що вони дума
про це що вони роблять ніхто не може
зрозуміти навіщо ця війна що вона які в
неї цілі і від кого вони нас захищають і
визволяють Росія вже не вперше атакує
храми УПЦ в Одесі приміром у березні
цього року удар прийшовся по чоловічому
монастирю тоді постраждало четверо
чинців та Ані цей випадок Ані руйнування
спасоу приображенського собору не
переконали релігійні громади УПЦ
донедавна пов'язаної з Московським
патріархатом приєднатися до православної
церкви України від початку року в Одесі
та області не відбулося жодного переходу
такий знаєте мав би бути поштовх дуже
сильний для того щоб зрозуміти що цей
русский мир вже не мир давно і і нам з
ним не подрозі але напевне тим
священникам які не хочуть переходити і
знову продовжують служити в так званій
Українській православній церкві яка по
факту є російською православною церквою
в Україні Московського патріархату далі
там продовжують служити і проповідувати
у зруйнованому Росією соборі кажуть
православну церкву України не визнають
тож і переходити до неї не збираються
який перехід куди переходити до кого
переходити в нас є своя церква яка яка
має 10 000 приходів є с є свій
предстоятель є свій свій синод який має
всі права який має поставляє її пископів
який церква яка варить своє Миро ці всі
це вс всі признаки Незалежності церкви і
узнайте те за кого ви мене питаєте які в
них є признаки Незалежності Загалом до
православної церкви України на Одещині
приєдналися лише вісім парафій УПЦ А у
самій Одесі жодного класичного переходу
люди котрі бачать що їх дурять і
обводять навколо пальця покида такі
громади і переходять до храмів
православної церкви України Ну ми в
цьому році це могли бачити на паскуу на
очну на Трійцю на інші великі свята де в
наших храмах кількість людей збільшилася
там в п'ять-шість раз але і
якби слабка сторона цього питання тому
що саме ці люди є активними і саме ці
люди могли би на
парафіях
організовувати кампанію по переходу
цілої парафії до православно церкви
України наразі в Одесі діє близько 70
храмів УПЦ донедавна Московського
патріархату А ось храмів пцу Лише п'ять
такий нерівний Розподіл - це результат
багаторічного російського впливу та
вливання коштів із РФ вважає історик
Юрій Демедюк крім того каже є й інша
локальна причина були періоди коли
е священнослужителі Української
Православної Церкви Московського
патріархату були
депутатами Одеської міської Одеської
от обласної ради інших місцевих рад що
це не як не прозрощення е релігії влади
митрополит Одеський Ізмаїльський
агафангел Московського
патріархату був не лише на зорі
Незалежності народним депутатам України
але і в 10-х роках він 2010х роках він
був депутатом Одеської обласної ради від
партії регіонів так само
настоятелька Одеського жіночого свята
архангела Михайлівського монастиря Надія
Шевчик матушка Серафіма була депутаткою
Одеської міської ради від тої ж
політичної сили за таких умов храми
тодішнього Київського патріархату ледь
виживали розповідає секретар Одеської
єпархії пцу ми завжди відчували гніт і
тиск
завжди несприйняття від влади ми не
могли Ввійти в кабінети От наприклад
мені один з чиновників
ее в 2000 десь третьому-четвертому році
я прийшов в рясі з хрестом тоді був
секретарем єпархії також і приніс
документи на реєстрацію але десь вони
мене поганяли по кабінетах і я висловив
своє незадоволення от то мені він сказав
приблизно так
Послушай пацан если ты ещё раз где-то
такое скажеш ты не то что не
зареєстрируешь даже в этот кабінет не
зайдёшь О так ми приблизно жили і коли
ставало чуть-чуть легше що ми могли
зайти в кабінет ми цьому дуже раділи і
старалися щось зробити проте тепер на
тиск і гніт нарікають уже в УПЦ
пов'язаної з МП так 19 жовтня Верховна
Рада підтримала у першому читанні
законопроєкт про заборону релігійних
організацій які пов'язані з РФ це
фактично запускає процес заборони УПЦ
пов'язаної з МП у свою чергу
представники церкви наголошують що УПЦ є
самостійною і незалежною а також
вважають що законопроєкт не відповідає
конвенції з прав людини та Конституції
України Я вважаю що в державі Кожний
повинен займатися своєю справою
журналісти
журналістами політики політикою церква
церквою
молитися і ніхто не повинен нікуди лізти
і тоді буде все добре І саме головне те
що
в ті час в ці часки тяжкі часи скрудні
треба всім навпаки
об'єднатися а нас беруть
роз'єднують тим часом частково
зруйнований спасопреображенський собор
хочуть відбудувати За підрахунками
Будівельників це може коштувати понад
200 мльонів гривень допомогу вже
пообіцяла Італія також чимало українців
долучилися до збору коштів на
реконструкцію люди вались навколо собору
і ще раз доказали що це улюблений храм
одеситів який вони готові якому готові
вони допомагати і
Я впевнений що з Божою допомогою
одесити опять його відбудують на останок
запитуємо Чи відреагували якось на
обстріл собору колеги священники з Росії
вони писали всі висловлюю співчуття та
там в сторінках зараз всі пишуть
на на соц соцсетях так а так Люди там
живуть такі ж люди як ми
і
дуже є якийсь процент люди які розуміють
цю безлузду війну ну вони нічого не
можуть зробити
тому це
дуже велика Шкода що християни воюють
між
[музика]
собою